I'm Alexander Rose the executive
director at the long now foundation as
some of you may know every month we try
and choose what we call a long short a
short film that exemplifies long term
thinking this month's was suggested by
one of our own staff Austin and the
title I was just told translates to sock
ology and it's a it's an interesting
example of choosing your environmental
battles
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
No and the moral is Alexander tonight's
talk comes from an interesting context
the Nature Conservancy is the largest
environmental organization it's said to
be the most trusted environmental
organization and that kind of thing
tends to go with a fair amount of
conservatism and tried-and-true
practices they've been enormous ly
successful so you don't screw around
with that on the other hand is the most
science-driven of all the environmental
organizations as 600 working scientists
in it and who we're hearing from tonight
is the chief scientist of all that and I
guess because of the science because of
who he is well this is not conservative
thinking Peter Kariba I must say I'm a
little daunted to be standing up here
Stuart's been one of my heroes for quite
a while but what I want to do is we do
have 600 scientists and and we argue all
the time that's and we're comfortable
with arguing so I'm going to give you an
argument tonight that began with me
reading this essay some of you may have
read it it it's an essay that talks
about the the the collapse basically of
the environmental movement and including
the conservation movement there been a
lot of other obituaries written about
environmentalism but when I read this
two parts of it that really really rang
true and it made me start to think and
so I it's over stated you know these
guys overstated it there it the
environmental we're not dead yet but we
are suffering some now you know this
we're dwindling our numbers are
dwindling as a fraction of the
population our political influence is
dwindling you certainly don't hear
any candidates for public office really
speaking out and taking on the issues
they may take on the issues but they do
it quietly and so one narrative about
that is that oh it's like to call
brothers who spent tons of money to stop
cap-and-trade and yeah they spent tons
of money but so did the environmental
side in fact recent analyses just
environmental side the pro kappa trade
may have spent more money so it's not so
simple to look at some of our failings
by thinking about it just as some sort
of evil oppas opposition loaded with
cash you know just burying us with their
advocacy and so I want to ask what have
we maybe been doing wrong so what have
we been doing wrong and I'm going to use
sort of three sources my personal
experience at conservation where I've
been working for 30 years I'm gonna use
some data and I mean it's just some
stories and and readings before we
diagnose where we've gone wrong let's go
back to where we were really healthy I'm
sure everybody in this room knows Rachel
Carson remarkable woman
so she was growing up you know 80 years
ago grew up at a really on a small farm
at eight years old she started writing
stories and 11 years old she published
her first nature article nature story
she graduated from in high school with a
graduating class of 44 she went on to
college and went to graduate school at
Johns Hopkins was really an outstanding
biologist but her father died and she
was left as the sole breadwinner for her
family for two sisters and her mother
and in those days there really wasn't
much prospect of a PhD woman getting
their job at the University so he'd she
had to follow a different career path
she went to work for what has now become
the US Fish and Wildlife Service it used
to be the Fisheries Bureau and she wrote
she wrote for the for the fisheries
Bureau she wrote their reports she wrote
for radio shows and then on the weekends
and at night she wrote and published
books and articles and I'm you all know
what
took on this is an ad from Time magazine
before a Rachel found her voice and then
published Silent Spring but the power of
that writing and what she accomplished
was was astonishing the this can really
be directly partially a trace to Rachel
she had a a personal meeting while she
was battling cancer and yeah and with
John F Kennedy science advisory board
and talked to them about some of the
issues and how we needed to take better
care of the environment and all of these
sort of cascaded out of that but it
wasn't without resistance if you've a
turn if you ever read her several
biographies about her but she was cast
there were remarks about her being a
really attractive woman and she wasn't
married so the best thing they could say
about her in that case was she must be a
communist and they said other things and
and and she she was many PhDs remember
she didn't have a PhD many PhDs attacked
her as not being scientific it's been
hysterical the word was hysterical that
was used about her she went on CBS
reports and was interviewed that 15 to
20 million viewers which was huge at
that time basically everybody was
watching it at Sunday night and she was
the one who wasn't hysterical the PhD
scientists were hysterical and as you
all know she won the day her book you
know quickly within three months sold a
hundred thousand copies and so we have
falling out of that and this in the 60s
that you know time passed that many of
us you know longed for nostalgically but
perhaps without much sense of realism
all those acts passed and now we come to
today and I'm only putting up one piece
of evidence but there are all sorts of
polls taken by the pew by the Yale
environment school by the Duke
environment school we take polls and
there's no question the trend is towards
a decline in support at large for the
environment this is just one of my
favorite issues because
of the remarks about Rachel Carson being
hysterical so do you agree with the
following statement most of the people
actively involved in environmental
groups are extremists not reasonable
people and 32 percent 96 43 percent in
2004 and just retake it and a little
over 50 percent so that you know I'm a
scientist I like to think of myself as
reasonable where is this coming from
how did we get ourselves in this
position where's there a lot of changes
going on
you may some of you may hope that the
blue line is the Democrats and the red
line the Republicans that's not the case
the blue line is the fraction of the
world's population living in cities the
red line is the fraction of the
population living wearily in 2008 they
they crossed for the first time and most
of the world lives in cities and it's an
expert in inexorable trend towards we're
good at we're going to be a very much a
totally urban world well that has
consequences I mean for for how we
connect to the environment there's no
question about that this is one of my
favorite statistics and Richard Louv is
written about this a lot of people have
written about this but basically there's
less and less connection with the
environment and with nature
so the college freshmen today's college
freshmen average less than an hour a
week in outdoor play growing up I bet
you almost every one of you sitting out
there averaged more than that every one
of you and I bet you is a lot more than
that and you know that that you there's
only so much you could get about the
environment by reading about it there's
another big change I can't see you
because of the lights but I bet you
reflect the demography on the left which
is basically whites in the majority for
the u.s. that's today the pie diagram on
the right is what is
that by 2050 White's will be in the
minority in the US it's already that way
in California by the way it's already
that way in California but I bet you
this audience doesn't reflect that I bet
you this audience doesn't reflect that
at all and so one of the things this is
something really interesting we just did
last month and I'm gonna come back to
talking about something we're doing in
the Conservancy in an experimental way
but we're collecting data on it we're
trying to connect with an urban and
different population because we think
it's it's necessary and so we yeah it's
pretty startling isn't it so let me tell
you who this this is Oakland San Antonio
in New York City focus groups in those
three places only those three places New
York City Oakland and San Antonio so
yurts Hispanics Asians and
african-americans and that was the
question we want you to imagine a person
who cares about nature describe that
person I love that picture
that's premise my daughter I think but
um she's blonde but but isn't it I mean
look at that preaches preaching we're
very preachy uptight uptight and that's
certainly you know that's how we appear
this new urban generation let me talk
about my a little bit for my personal
experience in the 80s I got involved in
litigation as an expert witness for the
Sierra defense legal fund and I was you
know I thought I was some sort of eco
hero you know I was young maybe 35 36
and and I would go into the courtroom
and I thought I was saving the
old-growth forest and and I was pretty
smug with myself thought it was just a
wonderful thing to do and I was taking
all this extra time and I was study late
at night so I could be good on the
witness stand but in one of the this is
a federal court judge Dwyer ran in
federal court in downtown Seattle and
one of the days I went in there and the
back of
room courts you know obviously maintain
order but in the back of the room we're
a bunch of loggers and they and they had
signs hung over them what they can't
speak up they can't interrupt science a
that said you care more about owls than
my children we're going hungry and they
had their kids on their shoulders you
know you carry your kids on your
shoulders and they shook them pull their
things and the kids would cry you know
you can't can't throw the kids out for
crying I'm at a time uh but was very
effective it was just ironic that it
that's my kids were exactly the same age
I mean there were exactly the or at the
age where I was walking around you know
you'd carry your kids on your shoulders
and you and you hold him like that and
it just sort of it really just squashed
any sort of smugness I had in any sense
of how one-sided the issue was and how I
was wonderful and saving the world and
it really made me think differently and
one of the other things I noticed is how
often do we talk about the planet as
being fragile you know anytime CN n
sends Anderson Cooper to an
environmental disaster he stands in the
middle of and says fragile Marsh fragile
River fragile forests if you go to the
websites of my organization included
Nature Conservancy WWF Conservation
International birdlife international and
scan their web sites when they talk
about habitats you will see it's almost
like they can't say a word about an
ecosystem without pressing it with
fragile and that might seem you know who
cares who cares that they do that maybe
it doesn't matter but it does matter
because when things are fragile and
you're convinced that they're fragile it
puts you in a position where you do not
negotiate because it might be you know
if you just give a little it's fragile
it'll be broken like that and it it
forces us to into these situations where
it's always fish versus humans that's
not fish and humans
it's miners versus
it's farmers endanger farmers versus a
danger
you know smell over and over again it's
in the either-or situation because
nature's fragile you can't tolerate any
of this activity I'll come back to the
science on this in a little bit but I
just want to you just think about how
often in the news media or on the
website you see that word fragile I bet
you you've use that I've used it and it
it forces us to do what it's called fort
fortress conservation if nature is
fragile then you keep people out you
keep it away and you know if nature's
fragile as I said no room for compromise
you hire armed guards I don't think when
Rachel Carson was thinking of
environmentalism she was thinking of
armed guards but now Africa you know you
set up parks you have to have armed
guards to catch the poachers in fact
that's common I mean i-i've seen for
many international conservation projects
a big part of the budget for armed
guards you basically have an army around
it and it's tragic when that happens
this should have been a really good
story this is a wonderful national park
being set up in the 80s in Uganda you
know roughly a little bit earlier than
our spotted owl trials seemed well
intended but what happened is they
forcibly evict evicted about 5,000
families because nature's fragile get
the people out forcibly evicted them
created a furor governments changed and
they let the the population back in and
the population was so pissed off and so
upset with the whole thing that they
just slaughtered the wildlife and why
did they slaughter the wildlife they
didn't want their lands being gazetted
be mapped as a national park to protect
wildlife that they couldn't live in
places it was their traditional land
that's not the way forward for
conservation
I'd say talons this is not human caused
but it was one of the scientific
experiences that made me think about
fragile this eruption and following the
rush a eruption as you might expect
biologists rushed out there to study it
and that plant on the left their little
tiny Lupin was one of the very very
first plants and I was a I swear there
are a hundred biologists around that
with measuring sticks and everything I
mean we there was just a wash would by
out we were all out there I study
bounced at Allen's along with a lot of
colleagues and if you get a chance you
know it's a terrific place to visit this
summer you could wonderful hikes there
but when you go there you'll be so
overwhelmed by how well that's bounced
back and you know what that eruption was
the equivalent of about a ten bombs
besides which we dropped on Hiroshima
keeping with that theme this is the
hydrogen bomb test we did in the de
bikini at all in the Pacific it's a
photo of that it vaporized Islands it
boiled the ocean boiled it National
Geographic recently sent an expedition
to look at what the coral looks like
there's 25% more coral there than there
ever was before four previous six all
right
I'm not saying I'd eat the coral but
nonetheless still the resilience of it I
mean obviously it bounced back partly
because humans weren't there to to fish
and and to do a damage but still the
resilience of it is remarkable they were
shocked Chernobyl Chernobyl has now been
declared a wildlife refuge because it's
got bear it's you know it's got cheval
skis the horse there the horse that you
see there is the subspecies a horse it's
it's you know basically from Mongolia
what Genghis Khan wrote across it
conquered the world with but it's an
amazing horse it thrives and breeds
there there's all sorts
major large vertebrates that don't are
anywhere else found in any numbers that
are thriving in this Haven this Natural
Park this is from San Francisco
peregrine falcon against it was once on
the brink of extinction there's a lot of
species that were on the brink of
extinction that we've brought back maybe
not as many as we'd like but still a lot
that we have brought back this is one of
them and now it delights many of us when
you can see it swoop down and nail a
pigeon I was just in Montana last week
we had our board meeting in Montana
there wasn't this much snow there then
although there's a lot of snow this year
but you can go to Montana now 15 years
ago you couldn't go but you can go to
Montana now and that's sort of a
wildlife tourists you could it's you can
count on if you know the right place is
the right time to go I've seen wolves
and coyotes and grizzly bears and bison
it's not a rare thing you can count on
it unheard of you know two decades ago
absolutely unheard of you all know this
photo this was one of those photos that
was where Anderson Cooper you know stood
in weeped
in the marshes of Louisiana talking
about the fragile ecosystem but the data
obviously this is a huge environmental
problem and does severe damage but there
will be recovery and in fact when Jayne
luchenko who's one of the longest
standing conservationists there is stood
up and showed this chart
she got massacred by the media this
chart basically showed data that told us
that bacteria were eating that oil much
faster than we thought why were they
eating the oil I mean just like oil is a
good energy source for us it's a damn
good energy source for bacteria and
there's a constant huge volume of oil
seeping a nap in the Gulf naturally not
anywhere near as much as that oil spill
but it's a constant supply you have a
rich fauna of highly evolved bacteria
you consume it and at water temperatures
warm in Exxon Valdez you didn't have
that recovery water temperatures cold
but she showed this data and it was like
a conspiracy because it wasn't damaging
enough somehow we were disappointed that
it wasn't as destructive as we you know
it's almost like we hoped for it to be
that much of a of a disaster and hoped
for the ecosystem to be that fragile now
let's look at some of our icons
obviously Henry David Thoreau is sort of
an icon goes out into the wilt the
wilderness alone he really didn't go out
in the wilderness he went to a pond in a
cabin you know not too many miles away
from Concord and as a you know as a kid
he he set one of the most destructive
fires by accident in outside Concord so
he's a very troubled youngster another
trub troubled you know young into the
wild person that met of not so happy
fate as Henry David Thoreau you may have
seen the movie or read the book but
another sort of this is a journey you
know going out into the wild and for
self-discovery but I want to draw
attention to Edward Abbey because I read
him when I was in college and I was
inspired I thought it was great and
there's a lot to to admire about Edward
Abbey but there was one part that and I
now feel cheated by and he also hated
this image of man alone in wilderness
it's always man by the way but man alone
in wilderness you know by themselves
with the loveliness of it and so let me
read you from Edward Abbey I wait now
the night flows back the mighty
stillness embraces and includes me I
could see the stars again and the world
is starlight I'm twenty miles or more
from the nearest fellow human but
instead of loneliness I feel loveliness
loveliness and a quiet exultation book
go to his personal journals written the
same time at its personal journals same
time he writes in him oh my god why did
he believe me why did he leave me his
wife why did she have to go back to New
Jersey I'm so lone
in fact he never mentions it there he
stole only the first year they had his
family with him the second year they
don't appear in the book they don't
appear in the book what is this myth
this is going to upset some of you but I
think part of the issues is we have to
face some of our metaphors and some of
the things we use John Muir certainly a
hero for conservation John Muir did not
have very pleasant views about Native
Americans and African Americans John
Muir our Native Americans
strangely dirty in a regular life these
dark-eyed dark-haired half happy savages
lead and forget when Yosemite was
created we kicked the Native Americans
out we actually I'd to have a fort
garrison there garrison troops and then
John Muir on African Americans Negroes
are easygoing and merrymaking a great
deal of noise and doing little work one
energetic white man working with a will
would easily pick as much cotton those
are our conservation heroes and you
wonder why we get some of the
disenfranchised urban youth this is much
less disturbing but no less wrongheaded
and it's our anti-technology bias one of
the things that's really always bothered
me I was originally trained in an
agricultural school was how
conservationists if if you're interested
in protecting habitat what's the first
things you do is you say how do we lose
habitat the primary source of losing
habitat is agriculture it's agriculture
and yet conservation organizations don't
seem to deal with agriculture don't
don't seem to you know get that we have
to feed the world and that we have to
find a way to feed the world because
that also helps us to a conservation no
question about that and well how can
they hold that idea in their head and
then be just knee-jerk anti genetic
engineering genetic and engineering is
not necessarily the answer for
everything and it's got risk and it
should be read
elated for sure but there are cases and
I'll come back to him where it might
help us but somehow we get religious
about this
in fact the nature conservancy finally
we you know we came to grips with this
that you can't really do conservation
without taking agriculture seriously and
actually trying to help agriculture do
its job
you just can't factor when Michelle and
I wrote we wrote a conservation biology
textbook actually conservation science
not biology but everybody else under
under textbook has pictures of animals
and pandas and tigers and we put a
picture of a farm on a conservation
textbook because we think that's part of
the key and I mean every mentioned it
there is this religiousness about the
environmental movement and these are
just some images that capture it I had
to give a talk at the New York Academy
of Science maybe a month ago and when I
mentioned that that we might consider
genetically modified organisms two
people in the audience got up they
didn't ask me questions they didn't want
to discuss it they just walked out angry
and you know that come on alright let's
have a discussion you can disagree with
that opinion but we could talk about it
with evidence with data it's it's if
this isn't a religion and it shouldn't
be a religion and then there's this
final thing it's it's what I call you
know we have a an amazing effect what
would I call it's sort of like
everything's gonna be dead tomorrow you
know somehow we seem to like telling
that story is the empty oceans you know
birds empty skies with birds and usually
when you look deeply it's not the case
in fact in every one of those it both
those examples it's not the case we talk
about the science behind it I first came
into this after I had been at a
university I bet it was spotted owls I
then went to work on salmon conservation
and this was a full-page ad
taken out in the New York Times about
extinction of the chinook salmon in a
Snake River and virtually every
environmental group signed onto it
Nature Conservancy did
I'm proud to say they actually called me
and asked me what the science was I
wasn't working for me the time but they
called me and said don't sign it cuz not
true and it was ridiculous
salmon is a little bit of a weedy
species this this says that for
certainty by 2017 if we take if we don't
take out the dams on a snake river that
should have salmon will be gone well
we're not the dams are not gonna be get
out by 2017
and I'll bet anybody their house that
there will be chinook salmon there
in fact I've made that bet when it's ad
came out and I and you know sort of thus
an understory of this as I went out with
a biologist for some of the
environmental groups and I said you guys
should know better you know you're
looking at the same survival data I am
and I won't name it the group but one of
the biologists yeah but last year was
our best fundraising year so my
caricature and this isn't fair is is we
could look misanthropic anti-technology
dogmatic anti-growth purist zealous
exclusive and romantic pastoralism and
all we ever do is say stop stop stop
don't don't don't know obviously you
know that's a caricature it's cartoon
it's unfair as a cartoonist collinear
the fragile but there's a parts of that
that's ring true to a lot of our
audience that we won't need to convince
and so you know the way forward is to
restore reconnect be people oriented
community oriented growth an opportunity
technology green infrastructure greening
business and you see these messages
picking up but I still don't think we're
aggressive enough about it in other
words not about what you can't do but
what about what you can do going forward
and before we do that and talk about
specific solutions you've got to deal
with the facts about the state of the
planet and not in a doomsday way not in
a way that oh my god everything's gonna
be dead tomorrow but to recognize our
footprint on the planet is huge so many
of you may have read this is covered in
a lot of the newspapers there's a push
to officially name this era as a new
geological epoch
called the Anthropocene and in other
words the human epoch because we so
dominate it
and we'd um you know climate change is
an obvious one but you've all seen these
pictures you know satellite photos about
the lights but there's so many ways we
dominate the planet you know we we take
sixty percent of the water for our uses
we dominate the nitrogen cycle we use
for to build our roads and our buildings
and all that we move more soil and rocks
to build things than all the geological
processes that used to move at all
move it all you know dams this is the
Glen Canyon Dam but behind there's more
water behind dams that are is free
running in rivers you know you could see
it from the satellite this is the Three
Gorges Dam yeah I don't know if you
could make it out but there's a straight
line in the lower left-hand corner
before that big body of water that's
about a mile across that's a Three
Gorges Dam huge impact you know there's
more treat there's more trees and
plantations than there are and for us
now so we dominate the planet but let's
not you know I I don't say that to to
say oh my god it's horrible because
there are still places where that there
is some wildness but there's no place
that's pristine it's untouched you go
and sample of vertebrates fatty tissue
you know Antarctic or Arctic and you'll
see in some of our pesticides in that
fatty tissue so that is let's get over
it that's the way it is let's move
forward but don't romanticize this
wilderness that really hasn't been with
us for a long time these are the
shipping lanes that show you know where
how out how much ships cross the oceans
so I'm sorry to pick on a B but you know
when your childhood heroes sort of fall
and you're fall down you know you get
upset so here's I'm writing about
wilderness wilderness the world itself
is mute the word itself is music
wilderness wilderness we scarcely know
what we mean by the term though the
sound of it draws all whose nerves and
emotions she just goes on and on about
wilderness and he talks of course about
desert that he's sitting in in Utah is
wilderness and he describes it
beautifully while he was there there
were 29 atomic tests at the test site
and he described him in his journal he
didn't put him in the book in the
description of the wilderness because it
would have messed up the picture he was
painting is how untouched it was we
can't seem to accept the world so going
forward what do we have to do well let's
embrace cities yeah we're of course
we're going to protect those wilds and
open places but that's not going to
succeed unless we as a conservation
movement embrace cities we started to do
that
the nature conservancy has an amazing
program in new york city it's been
running for 14 years now and it's now
it's being expanded we take kids usually
minority kids from inner city schools
and we take them out and they actually
work this is not fun and games it's not
an environmental education they work on
our reserves all over the country that
we have some in Montana this year work
it may be about 14 different states
first time away from home some of them
live in pretty rough you know situations
but they they work outdoors for us
removing invasive species building
trails helping with fences helping
usually work for scientists collecting
data recording data it's an amazing
program it's one of those you know you
meet these kids you go out with them and
it's yeah you feel really good about it
but these are some of the things they
say before I am I know I look ghetto but
I care about nature too my grandma said
not to go into woods because that's
where they hang people are you going to
reject me because I'm in a mall I'm a
Muslim they're really afraid you get
them in the first day they're afraid to
do this no question about it they've had
a lot of success stories so on our
magazine we show this kid Josh Carrera
who was you know homeless for a while
and now he's a star in college we show
these pictures of elation
but what's more interesting to me
because I'm a scientist is the numbers
yeah I think many of you may know that
the u.s. is falling behind in science
and technology other countries are doing
much better 6% is the percentage of
college majors origins who major in
science our kids these are kids that
went through the program they went
through a program in high school a while
back and we follow them it's greater
than 30% there are massive federal
programs trying to get kids into science
and none of them will achieve this rate
guarantee because they do it outdoors I
had to throw this in I don't know did if
this has hit the newspapers yet because
I haven't had a chance to peruse a
newspapers this was published in nature
maybe four days ago it's a premier
scientific journal fascinating about how
about life experience whether you live
in a city now and where you grew up how
much of your early life was spent
growing up at a city and they looked at
the population in cities versus towns
versus rural and you know previously
there been psychological things where we
know schizophrenia is at much higher
rate in cities and in rural populations
but they did MRIs so they did it's
really you know both wicked and wickedly
clever experiment what they did is they
had people take a test and it was our
test that was too hard so he couldn't do
it and then they paraded them it's
collect some of my teachers but they
just said you know you're not getting it
right you're going too slow it's not
getting right and then they took her an
MRI right afterwards to see what parts
of their brain racking up it turned out
that the people who are Worrell handled
the stress pretty well and the people
from the cities or people who who grew
up in cities as opposed to rural you
could see a mark a difference in their
brain imaging mark a difference and
that's the gray I mean those are graphs
on the right that scientists like to put
up there but it wasn't subtle it wasn't
a subtle effect he's a really dramatic
effect so it's get got written up in the
Economist you know I think you're gonna
hear a lot more about this study
interesting way to do an experiment but
that you know come on we spent a hundred
thousand generations
being hunter-gatherers we've had maybe
you know a couple hundred generations in
our current you know settled down town
and city thing those hundred thousand
generations have to had sort of
hardwired some things in us so I say
that that you don't see it's it's not
just about about its connecting kids
with nature's not just about saving
nature and maybe about saving the kids
but and it's possible in cities my dad
was a coal miner in Pennsylvania and in
early on I remember he took me to to
Pittsburgh in my memories of Pittsburgh
in the 1950s was not pleasant
I had no fond memories of Pittsburgh and
he says those are some early photos of
it recently we went back to Pittsburgh
for an ecological Society meeting and
ended up running along the river and
what an amazing story of river
restoration pittsburgh has done with the
three rivers that sit there beautiful
you know they it used to be so polluted
you didn't people didn't want to own
land along around it your it was so
corrosive your boats would corrode
there's no fish in it it was sludgy and
now they have a bass fishing tournament
they're a real success story closer to
home Guadalupe River this isn't the
nicer part of it near the airport you
can see a it's it's much better but I
have been coming to California for quite
a while I have a teaching appointment at
Santa Clara and you know it's amazing
how even this urban river has been
cleaned up enough so that you have steel
had in it technology
genetic modifications in favor of
conservation to here one of the pictures
the American chestnut which used to
dominate our Eastern forests got
devastated by a fungus having a real
hard time getting it back but there's
some you know you know some experiments
that are very very promising with
genetic engineering getting genes from
other species for resistance to the
chestnut blight to the disease are you
going to be anti genetic engineering to
say we can't get the American chestnut
back we can't use this genetic
engineering Oh would you would you
accept it I personally would accept it
food you know Bill Gates put put a lot
of money in a challenge to trying to to
improve agriculture in Africa and if
you're interested in conservation in
Africa you better be interested in
agriculture in Africa you better be
interest in agriculture in Africa and
one of the things that he's placed his
bets on that has some real promise is
cassava which right now gets hit by a
disease and is not as nutritious but it
it you know in the in the greenhouse
they've been able to genetically
engineer varieties that meet overcome
these obstacles if he could make that
work a genetically engineered cassava
that doesn't require fertilizer doesn't
require water much more nutritious and
resistant to disease are you gonna say
no because it's Gia it's a GMO I hope
not Elinor Ostrom the first and the only
woman to win a Nobel Prize in Economics
what did she win it for really
interesting piece of work she looked at
at resource management where normally we
think humans do a terrible job sort of
tragedy the common situations forests
marine protected areas fisheries grazing
where does not land ownership but
tragedy real tragedy the Commons and she
found that you could get successful
really successful management real
success stories she did this
scientifically she didn't cherry pick
things she looked at hundreds and
hundreds of case studies and said
sometimes we get good management and
good resources and other times we
destroy
what distinguishes them what
distinguishes in the power community if
a community can see the thing resources
it has the governance it works together
you get success and we've seen the power
of social networks but notice the sense
of community how different the sense of
community is from an isolated you know
man going into the wild to discover
himself doesn't like people you're not
going to get conservation as an
individual I those heroic pictures of
the lonely person off by themselves in
wilderness it's not how you're ever
going to get conservation it is the
power of community you know we saw this
the Nature Conservancy saw this because
we're working in the Gulf of Mexico and
you know we thought we had no idea what
we're getting into we we do oyster
restoration got about a million dollars
a mile of oyster restoration you restore
oyster reefs you doing a ton of get good
on so many fronts it's expensive
probably not more expensive than a levee
or something it takes a lot of labor so
we you know put out the word for
volunteers we were overwhelmed we
couldn't believe how many volunteers
would turn up for us so it's just like
jeez you know why didn't we think of
this before
and then this definition of wilderness
let's not be so exclusive and
narrow-minded in what we call wilderness
there's a book coming out by a friend of
mine Emma Maris it'll be coming out in
August called the rambunctious garden
this photo from the book is the Highline
Park that was created in New York was a
elevated rare rare old and then they
converted it to a park but they did in
an interesting way they landscaped it
they allowed some alien species in it
they didn't try to get all the alien
species out but they put in natural
species too and they landscaped it in a
very rough and ready way and it's maybe
this photo doesn't show it's beautiful
but if you're there in New York it
actually is beautiful
look at San Francisco where would San
Francisco be without you know the the
Golden Gate Park where would it be it
would be a desolate City yet in that I
mean you start to have wildlife you
stories about coyotes coyotes
you know why you keep your dog on a
leash that's great
maybe it's not great you have to keep
your dog on a leash but it's great if
there's coyotes they're not just you
know in urban cities you could flip it
around of this notion of wilderness
these are all shots from Indonesia where
we work and of course the upper right
hand corner is the pristine old-growth
untouched forest Indonesian tropical
rainforest which we do try to protect it
harbors an enormous amount of
biodiversity but we've learned that that
you know symbol of conservation
orangutan highly threatened species
turns out to do quite well in oil palm
plantations that's that's a dart for a
tranquilizer we're not trying to kill
the orangutan there that it's got out of
his side but you know we'd be really in
trouble if we did that but it surprised
us it just surprised the size of the
populations now certainly that does not
mean you want the world to go to oil
palm but it tells you you could tolerate
you know you can have some conversion of
oil palm and some old-growth and you'll
get more wildlife than you ever expected
near a pond it's not you know it's a
negotiating point just like you talk
about relaxing your definitions of
wilderness and nature we should think
about infrastructure in a different way
infrastructure shouldn't just be
concrete
Cannell you know canals levees water
treatment plants nature could be
infrastructure we have a number of
projects that show that this is a high
elevation sort of wet habitat it's like
a sponge if you walk out of the absorbs
water and all across South America we've
found that we can get an awful lot of
conservation done because people in
cities or companies in cities breweries
florists hydropower create funds to pay
for conservation upstream
simple idea it works and it's cheaper
when you do the economic analysis than
the engineering infrastructure it's
significantly cheaper and we actually we
don't lead with the nature conservation
when we propose these projects we lead
with the economic analysis and I think
they'll spread
I think it's viable for Asia could even
be viable for the u.s. something that we
really don't have working yet but the
Wall Street Journal mentioned it with
the Mississippi flooding so in a
traditional a natural river
you'd have flood plains the flood plains
would handle the extra water people
downs you know people wouldn't be
flooded out of their homes those flood
plains can often be really good at fish
habitats they'd also be there's
floodplain agriculture around the world
there's floodplain agriculture that
works quite well and we even do a little
of it here in California on some of our
areas but wall street journal' even
mentioned that maybe we should rethink
about how we're managing this river and
let the natural floodplains take over so
replace those levees which we had to
break because you know the water was
gonna crest and he do even more damage
downstream we had to break the levees
and and sort of instantly create a
floodplain I think there's real
potential there we haven't done the
economic analysis there yet but that's
something I want to work on personally
evil companies are not saying Dow is an
evil company but some people would you
got to be willing to work with the
companies and so this is actually not my
slide this is you know from the dow CEO
talks about a breakthrough collaboration
with the Nature Conservancy well why
would we work with Dow but Dow works in
37 countries 52,000 employees hundreds
of plants making plastics chemicals and
egg biotechnology which has huge demands
for water and resources and potentially
has huge impacts on the environment I
don't want to call dial the enemy I want
to work with Dow and figure out if we
could change the
activist I'm not naive may not work but
I'm not gonna say no at the outset at
all in fact the more the merrier the
more companies the merrier
and so maybe this is a cartoon from The
Economist you know maybe it's a matter
of finding the economic values and not
just speaking to the heart although the
heart is certainly important the heart
is why I'm in conservation heart might
be why a lot of you are in it but still
if you're gonna mainstream it if you're
not going to be a dwindling minority
speak to the economics because I think
there is a real economic argument to be
made you know wrap up a couple slides
and then we can have some chance for
some real argument and discussion I bet
you some of you know this painting
Picasso sort of inspired to to present
the horrors of the Spanish war and you
know that you have humans fighting and
animals in there you know fighting it's
just not a very pretty picture no I
don't want to be all touchy-feely you
know all everybody's nice and that's all
get along Kumbaya but in a sense the
environmental and conservation movement
has sort of proceeded in the world a
little bit too much about this it's it's
it's you know it's always been about
limits it's always about litigation you
know painting the other side as evil
without listening to them greedy stupid
this is no Picasso but some of you may
know this painting this is one of my
favorites by Quaker Edward Hicks it's
called a peaceable kingdom and look at
how well everybody's getting along there
you know all right that's a romantic
fantasy there's no question of that
being a romantic fantasy but certainly
given those two artists you know those
two competing artistic renditions this
is more what we have to get towards but
I don't want to use you know a painting
I'm gonna use some photos to sort of
finish off my argument
so yeah you know it is I want wild
things I want to save spectacular
species you know I love the fact that I
could see grizzly bears absolutely love
it but you know to succeed
we'd better be able to work really well
with Republicans Nixon was a
conservation hero he signed the
Endangered Species Act go back and read
the words he said when he signed the
Endangered Species Act effect talk about
an era gone by when the endangered
specie Act was signed it was unanimous
in the Senate unanimous not a single
Republican voted against it they
dangered species act unanimous and
nowadays it's guns so that you know in
the primaries I know from talking this
to to you know Republican politicians
that Republicans in primaries are as
likely if not more likely get attacked
for donating money to a conservation
group as they are for their stands on
abortion that's really messed up and
it's not messed up don't blame theirs
it's it's you know how we've dealt with
it sure they have responsibility but we
have responsibility to we will get
nowhere in conservation if it's
Democrats versus Republicans
as well look at the diversity of that
photo that's what the world looks I like
when we turn up the lights and look
around the audience I guarantee you you
don't look like that guarantee you don't
that's the diversity of people we have
to bring took the conservation and
that's going to take work we're gonna
have to break down some of those myths
of those kids from Oakland and San
Antonio New York City who talked about
us as being preachy and uptight
biotechnology and Technology in general
there's a knee-jerk religious
ideological response
against technology among many
conservationists this is a picture of
brown and yellow rice where the yellow
rice is genetically engineered to have
vitamin A which is really important for
health in many parts of the world but
you know you know Greenpeace
wanted to block all this ardently you
know just block any sort of genetic
engineering of the crops we can't be
knee-jerk against technology you have to
evaluate it as a scientist not as an
ideologue and they'll be risk with any
technology but there's also risk to not
pursuing it corporations and cities you
know if it's just about conservation and
appealing to these spectacular places
with the animals that we love and we
don't deal with the cities and
corporations we're also doomed to
failure so I don't want to you know this
is an argument I make inside the
Conservancy and we're doing you know
we're experimenting with all this we
have an agriculture group we've started
consciously thinking about urban
conservation both in terms of connecting
to urban populations but actually doing
River restoration actually doing
conservation in cities we're paying
attention to the notion of diversity and
I haven't been successful quite yet but
I'm trying to get us more and more
comfortable with with with technology
I'd even like us to have on our webpage
site saying something like I would like
us to say something like genetically
engineering you know genetic engineering
food planets is you know a potential
option it could carries risk has to be
regulated has to be evaluated but it's
not something you should say no to
outright but we'll see
I'll keep arguing why don't I stop there
and I hope we have lots of questions
that could have a good discussion about
somebody's I guess
[Applause]
wonder why Kevin put this on top from an
Roberts are there any groups the Nature
Conservancy would refuse funding from
that's a good question
so like at all it you know probably
organizations we have what we call a
risk committee its standard operating
procedures and there are groups that we
would refuse funding from and it would
be if we thought it would be their
intent was not at all serious that it
was just sort of a greenwashing thing it
would dig and it would damage our
reputation more than the benefits so and
we've had we do have debates about that
I wanted to I I wanted to have a green
car for NASCAR
I thought that would be great um and but
I got shot down but I don't think it's a
good idea so you say the argument is of
the essence and you've got six hundred
scientists okay what's part of the some
of the current debates within the
scientists within Nature Conservancy
like is GMOs a debate or is everybody
think it's a good idea you know I think
everything that I mentioned is it's a
debate among a scientist to be honest
the GMOs is a debate there's a debate
about what do we demand of a corporation
well we work with it I actually think I
probably wouldn't say no to any
corporation as long as the data were
public mm-hm and you could use it and
there were measures in place to see
what's happening so that happens to be
my stance so I really push us to be a
little bit more open to corporations but
then to be a little bit invest more
person power and staff into seeing what
they actually do we have a debate about
that we have a debate about alien
species and invasive species we have
debate about what are the objectives of
conservation
what's the nature in the of the invasive
species to be again so the you know as
many of you probably know there's
there's both internationally and
nationally there is evidence that
non-native species alien species can
come in and do severe damage they're
implicated the extinction of some
species specially on islands or
ecosystem damage that's caused a big
reaction to try to reduce it alien
invasive species by keeping them out at
the borders with by when they come in
trying to control them and then in some
cases trying to eradicate them everybody
agrees on that
the debates a bit more polarized than I
thought I think it needs to be there's
one camp that gets characterized as
invasive species are horrific and let's
knock ourselves dead and spend all the
money in the world and do whatever it
takes to get them out even though
whatever it takes has its own costs
that's one extreme the other extreme
says and you know it costs us so much
there's better uses for the money let's
relax let's relax so it's it's really a
debate about the cost effectiveness and
the wiseness of investing in control you
know so I've had a sense that especially
in Islands invasive predators can turn
things really seriously upside down but
invasive plants alien plants basically
just increased the biodiversity like in
New Zealand is this what you see down
the plants make other plants go extinct
so what your your district depiction of
islands is dead-on accurate mm-hmm
in plants I'm trying to think and I may
not know the literature I don't know
that many examples of the making of go
extinct as you said it you know now
California has 25% more plant species
now that it had a couple years a couple
of years ago because of invasive species
the only alien species have increased
our plan
versity that's a kind of make you think
about that I think of what so wouldn't
that okay so that's the primary for like
level I mean we get that many more
plants do we wind up getting that many
more creatures living on the planet so
the whole biodiversity gets enriched so
well now I doubt it cascades through to
vertebrates and stuff like that the
problem with with with invasive species
plants as they may not cause extinctions
but they can do a lot of damage to
rangeland undoubtable they could be you
know in their case their wheat they're
there almost in those cases and economic
a burden and an agricultural weed so
that may not cause it's not a
biodiversity argument that's an economic
argument and it's a valid argument
there's the nature conservancy use
herbicides against some of these yes we
will use they're precise in some cases
gosh Kevin Kelly says you suggest that
environmentalism has become dark mattock
and quasi-religious are you afraid that
religion might add environmentalism to
their own dogma I'd listen there's some
background in this I've been part of you
know we did scenario planning the Sierra
Club and we said it a certain one of the
things that emerged from that session
was that there was Christians who would
like to protect God's creation and that
there was a whole green movement ready
to happen from among Christians the dead
Wilson wrote a hold right Kevin is
asking should we worry I wouldn't you
know interested wait so I think about
nature conservation as there's a lot of
reasons to do it there's economic
reasons there's our personal ethical you
know the inspiration we may take about
it take from it and I actually think it
would be a frankly great if some
religions adopted it it's part of the
diversity thing in in a sense it's
broadening the constituency
it broadening the constituency for
conservation means it's not just you
such as to us and we've had conferences
where we've invited you know faith-based
groups and its values and if and if
religion wants to champion the values
of conservation I'm fine with that I
don't have to agree with their religion
but if that's motivating I'm actually
fine with that all right
Byron asked all the news that I read
says we're now living through the third
greatest mass extinction in the planets
history do you have an opinion about
this it seems you discount much of the
negative news and the press these days
about our environments decline are we
having a mass extinction we're certain
so that you know the the you know by all
evidence the extinction rate now is an
order of magnitude higher than it then
sort of background levels order of to
order of magnitude in order to I don't
came Wow 10 times yeah but on the other
hand there have been claims about the
extinction rate that have been Elise een
these like one species goes extinct
every you know 20 minutes that have been
a little bit exaggerated and one of the
interesting things is is that when you
actually look at the extinctions you
have to ask you know have they had those
dire you know consequence chestnut
passenger pigeon those are those are not
rare species
those are huge massive extinctions and
it hasn't actually caused the end of the
world
so extinction is is is something that I
think we want to minimize we care about
it but it's not it quite as apocalyptic
as some would say it has consequences
but I wouldn't say it's is apocalyptic
so what happens to Paul Ehrlich's rivets
to the airplane model is when I was
studying at Stanford in the 50s the
ecological understanding we had was that
there's these ecological communities and
they're very deeply integrated and
they're fragile and any loss of any part
of it as a loss to the whole thing are
you saying that's not the case so there
are so the rivet that's a it's a good
probably metaphor it's hard to turn off
it was hard to not be persuaded by that
metaphor but if you if you think about
what really goes on
first of all it's it's not it's not an
airplane that's flying it's kind of a
jalopy that's rolling along the ground
and it could you know it's a little bit
not quite such a exquisitely designed
thing the second thing is that species
you know for sure you lose rivets and
what you're left would with is different
mm-hmm so when we lost top predators
when we you know lost Wolves initially
and grizzly bears and when we lose tuna
in the oceans it changes but the ocean
does not stop you know functioning as an
ecosystem it's different and and and so
I think what's wrong about his analogy
is is the notion that something crashes
to the ground and burns that all the
passengers died that's not what happens
if you get something different a
different ecosystem so one of the
surprising things to me is the idea of
this integrated ecological community
seems to have sort of passed from
ecology and and species are headed in
various directions at various times and
it's sort of like working in an office
where you're really intimate with a lot
of people but then you know you move on
somebody loses their job and the office
carries on without you and it's not like
a family where that is close and
perpetual and so are all these species
just sort of working at the office I
like that I think that's the counter to
up into Paul's metaphor it may well be
you I mean I know you studied ecology
early on but there was a it still exists
from the fifties onward there's been a
debate about eco
ecological systems and one is about the
super organism the community and the
other one is this is really jargony the
individualistic species sorry and and I
think they're not down to the selfish
gene right and and I think now you
probably you know that the feeling is
more towards the individualistic species
so all the field biologist
that I know are seeing climate change
happening in whatever habitat they're
studying and presumably you're seeing
the office metaphor play out there
because some species are doing one thing
with the change of climate some are
doing another some were dependent on
each other in certain ways that the time
thing is flowered and the bugs arrived
in the birds arrived and all that kind
of stuff and that's all in flux what
happens then is it is it just a case
where basically the weeds take over and
until the climate change settles down
again or what's going on I think I think
climate change is gonna challenge us
thinking about communities in such a
profound way and we do see it it's
interesting so suppose you have plants
that hold soil so they they reduce dust
storms a very important function that
maybe doesn't matter which plant species
does it but you need a plan to do that
climate changes and you lose the plant
that currently does it you know what's
gonna replace it I think I think we're
you know in my world I would start to
get proactive about it I would start
there and say climate changes on us
let's you know let's think about what
the grasslands and for and you know arid
lands and forests in the future what do
we want them to look like what functions
do we want to make sure we maintain and
maybe even help move some species around
the anticipation so what does adaptive
conservation look like adaptive in the
sense of adapt and adapting the climate
change so safe do you have to do you
know climate they're the environmental
and conservation movement uses climate
adaptation in two ways one way is use
things like oyster reefs flood plains
and marshes to provide adaptation to
storms and floods so they do less damage
to us so that's using nature to help
protect us instead of losing concrete
the other way they use that word
adaptive comfort the conservation is you
know in the spirit of where we want to
you know we give an example of an idea
that's out here it's relevant to
California
there's Island scrub J on Santa Cruz
Island
you know smallest population of a bird
in North America tiny population
obviously at risk of extinction Western
Nile virus if it gets to it
Western Nile virus has come to
California if it hit this one population
we can lose a species adapted
conservation of may would be let's
create some more populations ourselves
go in as managers you know put some on
some other islands to to anticipate
change so we get its it's being more
protist waiting for stuff to happen to
us don't wait for stuff to happen to us
now you mentioned American chestnut
which is sort of one of the tragedies
that I my family paid attention to when
I was growing up and I gather the
American chestnut was like forty percent
of the eastern deciduous forests with a
certain point and it was raining down
these sweet nuts that all the animals
are living on people are living on and
then it evaporates and the things carry
on and now you say there's a GMO version
of the American chestnut that is poised
to come back so there's Nature
Conservancy pushing that or standing by
or what can I don't speak for the Nature
Conservancy but don't forget there was
also salmon in the river that you could
walk across as well the the you know so
the it's not ready to there's research
about getting resistance genes actually
inserting them into into the embryos so
getting chestnuts that are resistant to
the fungus that it yep know where they
get the genes from a number of different
places one was a daffodil I can remember
some of the other places work but other
species so that's a class you know
that's genetic engineering
they're moving DNA from one species into
another why do you need genetic
engineering you can't even grow the
things up you know to cross them by the
natural ways there at the K that the the
situation where they get it in the
greenhouse
mmm-hmm so the next step would be to do
feel field trials with it
you know if if my boss came to me and
said should we be for or against these
field trials I
we should before is anybody against them
I'm sure that they're that a lot of
groups are against them or yeah well you
know I I did hear one complaint about
what with gee if we get a engineered
successful American chestnut it might
become invasive right and you know it
with that so does he it's not just
American chestnut there's a whole
genetic engineering proceeded very far
with crop plants animal plants or
Bhatia's plants and now you could do a
lot of trees it could be engineered
deport you know biomass carbon
sequestration plantation and people
think about you know you worry about
weeds what about an invasive trees and
chestnuts we would be glad if then right
but so I think you could you know what
the national academy of science says
about this is it's not the technology
it's not the fact you move the DNA
around
it's the traits you examine the traits
as a scientist and ask you know what are
the ways in which it can alter the
performance of the plant where might it
end up and what's a do a cost-benefit
analysis so that you'd have to analyze
it on a case-by-case basis which isn't
that hard okay predators
you mentioned passenger pigeons there
used to be something like five and a
half billion passenger pigeon eyes in
North America one explanation I saw said
that's because the their predators the
Native Americans had been largely
extinguished like 90 percent
extinguished by European diseases and
then the passenger pigeons took off
along with the Buffalo that you think
the case it's certainly the case with
the Buffalo I hadn't actually heard that
you about passenger pigeons but it
certainly having predators have the
capacity to hold populations down to
pretty low levels and you remove look at
the deer and all over the East Coast
you know maybe predators have a real
ability to control their prey
populations and you get rid of the
Predators and
you get a plague almost of the prey so
you've got to have people behaving like
predators keep the deer down so bow
hunting in town is a good idea in the
garden the twins take that one more
thing in the passenger pigeon the last
one died in 1914 was stuffed and sent to
the Smithsonian the several are stuffed
ones there's one at Harvard I know of
one in Ottawa so there's plenty of
tissue there for presumably really good
intact DNA you know where this is going
and I've bioengineered George Church
about this and he says it looks like the
closest genetic relatives the
band-tailed pigeon which there's plenty
of and that basically you could once you
have sequence both of them start
tweaking the band-tailed to become the
passenger pigeon and bring this extinct
totally iconic species back to life what
do you think of that so I think I wish
you and I have had a little bit of this
discussion before but I knew he wasn't
going to completely turn blue but so you
know you have one side of conservation
that is about preserving the past and
then you have the other side of
conservation that is about building a
future what do you want the future to
look like preserving the past is
impossible because of so much change
mm-hmm
doing all only about the future is
dangerous because you do you wouldn't
potentially end up with a Jurassic Park
you know you can in your your hubris
your your arrogance as a scientist you
could sit there and say I want you know
I would mammoths Neanderthals I'd like
Neanderthals you know let's get all
these things back let's let's create a
spectacular future you know I'm a little
bit frankly leaning towards a little bit
preserving the future I I would like to
see a discussion of the passenger pigeon
I'm not sure I'd start with the
passenger pigeon there's other species
that you like the Tasmanian Devil but
things like that
predators your eyes
you know that I think California grizzly
you're gonna bring the California
grizzly back a known maneater right can
we tweak it so that it's afraid that
people like right but I mean that's
reasonable right can we do that we do
know how you know there's some simple
genes of all with domesticating animals
but but but I
and probably humans and if we silence
those genes we go feral again all right
this was interesting
that's the hippo that's the brain imager
eivol we saw some people in the aspirin
it's the environmental forum there and
one guy was saying that so well you know
chickens are basically dinosaurs as we
all know and if you can sort of
basically silence the chicken genes and
during out the emergent dinosaur we can
bring back the dinosaurs they're
predators some of them okay Dan Esther
factory farms more sustainable than
low-density organic farms now that
you're focusing on agriculture you're
gonna have questions like that you know
that's it you know so the the the whole
issue of farming is a is a is one of
those issues that it's gotten
ideological as opposed to you know
evidence or data based and that's the
type of thing we're gonna have to look
at I'm not ducking the question but one
of the interesting things is is you know
doing that accounting land use energy
use water use not just land use its
water use and pollution I feel like both
sides in in this debate don't speak from
evidence they speak from belief and I
don't we actually know that data that
well but when I've looked it's it's I've
often found surprises like grass-fed
beef is one example you know in
situations like that
what's a grass-fed beef is is an example
where the USDA just you know decided to
put a label on what is called grass-fed
beef you all know I mean grass-fed beef
is it's healthier for you much healthier
for you and I'm for the landscape I
think and for the landscape no question
about that but they put a label on very
dogmatically and they said it's gonna be
grass-fed if it absolutely he's only
glass
that makes it really hard for it to be
economically viable it needs a little
bit to be able to get things quickly to
the market when the market ask for it
you want to have it have a little grain
feeding not much but a little data shows
in this case where a little grain
feeding doesn't really have that big
impact on the environment and it doesn't
change the quality to meet health wise
but it's a case of a regulation
potentially being dogmatic because it
just wants to be absolute and I think
that for a lot of our practices if
instead of organic being an ideologies
and factory be the ideology you instead
had outcomes what's the outcome you want
the outcome you want is the healthiest
possible meat with the least use of
carbon and water and land and then take
those as your measurable outcomes and
find the system that creates those as
opposed to falling into labels
so we label our agriculture when we
should make it really outcome oriented
with data and we can collect there's
nothing you can collect better data then
for the Negra culture you guys are
around the world in how many countries
37 37 countries and what you spelled out
this evening look pretty much the United
States oriented in terms of population
and cities and things like that
do you have completely different issues
in different parts of the world not at
all so you know that we already went
through our organization China has gone
through urbanization Africa hasn't yet
Africa Africa's does the continents
that's just I think 37 percent over in I
can't remember the figures exactly but
but this urbanization trend is global
and what that means for the populations
is hugely it's going to be hugely
important similarly the you know the the
when people live as farmers are on the
land they have some sort of connection
to nature when they move into the cities
when Africa urbanize --is and as China
has urbanized you you end up with a
totally different sense of the of the
environment that's gonna be common
the I I think the tension between
economic growth and corporations in the
environment that certainly exists in
China China actually is more
environmental than you might think
because they've seemed the pollution and
they've seen how damaging it is and
their struggle is how can they have
economic growth and befriend
corporations would still be
environmental that's a problem that
applies in every continent in every
country we work does China focus on
biodiversity and wild lands and things
like that I when I first got hired by a
Nature Conservancy I went to China to
teach a course of conservation and I was
by our connection said how to do it for
their government sort of high-level
government people and I started talking
about biodiversity they had no interest
they would think they would just what is
it they didn't they had no idea what it
was they have a thing called ecosystem
function and they define ecosystem
functions well that sounds like you yeah
yeah I stole it from China and they
cared about it a lot I could get the
species back into it
by not talking about biodiversity I find
biodiversity little abstract but I got
species into it like the golden Eun and
monkey or mushrooms
China has a tremendous you've got
restaurants of China and all chewties
mushrooms you know it desert mushrooms
mushrooms it tastes like steak mushrooms
you know it just all sorts of mushrooms
they export them to Japan make a lot of
money off them that's diverse and they
have a real sense of mushroom diversity
so we could you could actually get them
interested in mushroom diversity but not
by diversity in our abstract way of
thinking about it yeah you know the
mycelium maniacs good right lead the way
there Stephen has political question the
people fighting conservation are
powerful is Ellis unethical and
single-minded in their attacks on
conservation
if conservationists are reasonable they
will lose by D radicalizing the
environmental left and pushing the left
toward the center aren't you just paving
the way for a victory by the
unreasonable ultra right
I actually don't see it so when I first
went to work for the Conservancy I was
you know I was very you know that's why
I testified I get spotted owls you know
I wanted to be out there on the
barricades and I went to work and I
actually was put on the board for the
Conservancy not work for him and I went
in there taking all these corporate guys
you know what what do they like you know
and I was I went in there with the worst
possible expectations I interviewed them
all I keep little notebooks and I'd ask
them over drinks why do you do this
without exception and my sample size is
like 40 or 50 they had deeply personal
reasons they were they were reasons that
often had to do with their kids and they
wanted their kids to see something or
have an experience they were very humane
and I and I and I stopped demonizing
them I don't I think you does you know
service to demonize your opposition and
I'm not being a goody-goody there I'm
you know cynical about work you would
Dow I know Dow has to make a lot of
money I know that I know they're gonna
have to make decisions but they're also
well intended humans they want to do
nobody wants a worse world nobody
actually wants to destroy the world
you know maybe they want to make money
and it's a trade-off but you know it's
it's I just don't see it as that good
and evil and that's the problem related
question I think from Lorraine Palmer
please comment on the in a legal right
of non-human species to inhabit this
planet and thrive not in service to
humans but simply to live their lives so
I personally think as a value I mean the
way I think about that is we should not
be responsible for the extinction of a
species you know you know that's my
value I do not but that's a value and a
different culture and a different
country might have a different value
that's a value decision and I'm not
going to impose my value on them the
metaphor I use it we use it in the book
and other people have used it you know
to to some people if you
if to save a thousand kids you had to
for some perverse reason extinguishes a
species that has already been dwindled
down to a few hundred individuals you
know what choice would you make people
would have a hard time making that
choice so that is a value question and
it's my personal value but I think it
has to be decided by political process
in any country we've decided by our
political process because the Endangered
Species Act we feel that way about other
countries might now just make a
difference one of the things I run into
is is trying to often does astoundingly
green things that are just starting
lately fast rate in a large scale and
one notice is that the entire Politburo
is run by people trained as engineers
and scientists this is not the case in
the United States for an entire
Politburo is lawyers should we be
getting more scientists and engineers
and people of those backgrounds in
political office as well as being
appointed to things well and the
Conservancy there's probably six
scientists for every lawyer good ratio
but good yeah you know i don't you know
i'm not sure scientists are are any
wiser about these issues either I might
if I might want anthropologist
anthropologist yeah boy there's a
formula for argument Kevin Kelly has a
question is probably a good last
question for the evening can you paint a
picture of your best-case scenario
successful conservation in an urban
planet over two hundred years is the
long now foundation so what is a long
term high-tech eco topia look like so I
well I love the idea of you could topia
but I think you know the the the
high-tech eco topia is cities that are
infused with parks so that people come
in contact with nature I mean all the
riparian zones all the rivers restored
no reason they couldn't be so city's
rich with parks things that are that you
know I know they're not pristine but
wilderness areas that that somehow allow
urban people to get to them agriculture
that is conducted to maximize yield and
minimize water and energy use which
again as I say is is that's an output
that's not organic agriculture and it's
not industrial agriculture
it's an output you can engineer towards
with technology and if and I think
there's a lot of degrees of freedom the
planet still isn't that overloaded the
population is going to level off soon
and mining and energy extraction
situations where if the mining and
extraction is done in a case where it
really will do damage that it's really
slow to recover from than offset
payments offset payments extracted from
those corporations to pay for
restoration elsewhere it still leaves
some plenty of money to make a lot of
profit that would be basically my
ingredients how about the oceans it so
as you in the oceans the buzzword now is
ocean zoning or marine spatial planning
necessarily would Noah and Jane would
chenko land is being pushed all around
that's very much that idea in the oceans
do you will succeed in the oceans not by
telling people they can't fish but by
telling people they could for sure fish
here but over here they can you got it
you you can't just be that stop sign
it's got to be a stop sign with a green
light in the oceans as well so you quote
Elinor Ostrom
Nobel prize-winning sort of economist
who talks about managing the Commons I
guess that this scale the Kevin is
talking about which is planet scale and
multi century scale what is managing the
Commons made of it's it's this a form of
governance that is extremely local and
grassroots ease somewhat global
what are we looking at here to manage
the Commons that planet-scale
in the Anthropocene so you know there's
all sorts of futurists that write about
this my own little futurist vision of
that is that our you know social
networking IRA you know these things
mm-hmm
I would like to it's like my idea for
for climate change is it's so hard for
people to to believe in client that
climate change is happening is is I
would like to have an app and the app
allows you to take pictures of birds the
birds are easy and iPad picked of the
set of species it gives a GPS
coordinates you know exactly where it is
and you know we that it's range is
expanding and you create a community
that through this is aware of your part
of tracking what's going on in your
environment and I think the social net
you know it's not I bill mckibben calls
them I pad idiots
and I think he's idiot for saying that
because we have to embrace that culture
that's the you know that's where we're
going to get the sense of community is
is if people feel connected this way and
could share data I could share
information I bet you if we got this
iPad I don't know what species I pick
but I bet you if I got this set up and
you could take pictures of birds and you
could find out this is the northernmost
this has ever been and that was
broadcast all over the world you know
and there are other people other places
say this is the northernmost I'd ever
get it would people would suddenly say
wow things are changing and it would
become real to them and they become you
know part of that so that's my future is
assured thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you